my good friend a guy who I used to
pester every Monday on something I saw
on Sunday he's Mike Pereira NFL on Fox
rules analyst Mike how are we doing
today Mike no really no what's this
about you know what no Mike you know
that I have to tease you because every
Monday or even Sunday nights rules that
I saw or plays that I saw I always
needed clarification from you well guess
what yes you'll need more clarification
from me this year because while things I
think in the area of the catch are
somewhat clear yes I think there's the
confusion now as this lower to the head
initiating contact so I think I'm
insured of a job for another couple of
years because we'll have this will have
this confusion yeah so al River Ron's
gonna be the one under firing you got a
haffley hopefully explain when people
come to you Mike of what is this actual
rule we're calling it the targeting rule
I know it's different than college but
could you in your term kind of explain
what the NFL is thinking with passing
this rule well obviously they took a
look at analytics they took a look at
the data that showed that there were
more concussions um this year than the
past and and so they decided to take the
the big step which they have been
talking about Kirk I'm telling you since
the you know 2005 I mean I used to sit
in my office in New York and the command
center and they would come back to to me
and say you know as we're looking at
these defenseless players and leading
with the crown of the helmet let's just
make it illegal period because the rule
book currently back in in the early
2000s supports it because there is a
rule on the books right now in rule 12
that says you know you're a player's
prohibited from you know what's called
they use using any part of a player's
helmet or facemask - but spear or RAM an
opponent violently or unnecessarily so
the powers to be who were scrambling
then fairly early on in the concussion
front you know we're saying let's make
all helmet contact leading with the
helmet contact
- FAL and I would fight it and say it's
impossible it's impossible to take the
you know the head out of the game to
that degree and then I think in Dean
bland Dino's day after me you know with
this rule being in there was that wasn't
being enforced he said let's take it out
of the book and they said no it's a
player safety issue and now they have
come full circle and said we're going to
enforce it with new language that says
you can't initiate contact with your
helmet anywhere at any time and it's
initiate and make contact and as I've
sat back now and kind of digested it and
talked to Al River on for a while I
think what we're going through now is a
bit of an overreaction I think back to
four years ago when they put in the
crown of the helmet rule with the runner
and the person the the defender that's
trying to tackle the runner everybody
was saying we were going to have so many
fouls and in fact I think there's been
six called in four years so I do think
it's a bit of your overreaction but it
is a significant change in the
interpretation I think it will lead to
more fines than it will actually fouls
although there there will certainly be I
think a an uptick on on the crown of the
helmet hits but I think Kirk to say that
it's going to happen you know on every
time there's blocking in interior line
play and that type of thing is
nonsensical common sense will will seek
its level and and I think it will be
okay but you know they're making a huge
point of emphasis on this and and it is
somewhat going to change things you know
my watching both games the college game
in the NFL game I know you you know
watching you on Sundays it's the NFL but
I love to listen to you on Saturdays
whether I'm broadcasting the game or I'm
done and I you know hear a rule that
needs to that you're explaining in the
college game as a rules analyst for
college football as well Mike how does
this differ this targeting rule in the
NFL the changes from
the rule in college you know they're
targeting rule which is more of a
defenseless player is the NFL really
just kind of taking a book out of the
college ranks and trying to have their
own adaptation or to the rule in the NFL
to a degree yes because the college rule
is two parts you know there is one part
for the defenseless player and then
there is the second part which basically
says you can't lead with the crown of
your helmet period and it applies to all
players and all you know hitting all
opponents so that's really that part of
it is what the NFL is saying now without
the ejection without the automatic
ejection force in which college that's
my big objection is that you know you
end up getting you know players ejected
for what I call marginal hits not
flagrant hits and the NFL will never go
down that line I mean it's two different
games you're talking about 46 active
players versus a hundred in college
could be or more so they'll never go
down that line now they they throughout
the notion of these helmet hits which I
really believe is only to say that if
the officials do on a leading with the
helmet hit if they do go ahead and eject
the player on the field then the office
in New York can take a look at it and
say hey did it in fact merit an ejection
I don't think and and and I'm sure that
we're not gonna get to where college has
gone to where replay can stop the game
if a hit wasn't called you know and then
put a personal foul on I'd really
caution you know using the word
targeting and if I write the NFL I would
never I would say don't ever use
targeting because it leaves a bad taste
in people's mouths but I think that
there really it is adapting part of the
college rule without the ejections and
please I heard some things this morning
oh my god you know ten players are gonna
get you Justin's in the first quarter
you know it's not going to happen it's
not going to be automatic there's going
to be an uptick but New York is only
get involved with these ejections and
what I have read so far and that is if
the officials call a personal foul for a
non football act so we're not talking
about a you know a pulling guard hitting
you know a corner coming around the edge
in that's a football play ejections that
happen you know on the field or don't
get called I should say personal files
that are called on the field but do not
the officials don't eject the player
that the league can only stepped in if
it's a Gronkowski type thing where you
file on the back of a guy or a Mike
Evans thing when you just come racing
across the field and nail a guy who's
standing still on the sidelines um let's
just I think we're overreacting a little
bit yeah but that's what we like we love
to do that Mike you know that yes and
you know and I must admit the last three
days I was actually fishing up an organ
and who nice when I looked at my phone
and I read that you know that they had
passed this new rule I think I missed a
good take on a steelhead because I was
pretty shocked I didn't I didn't expect
it to happen but then you know then when
I talked to people and and and kind of
look at it from the historical aspect of
the lowering the helmet the crown of the
helmet rule I really it's gonna change
there's no doubt but I don't think that
they have ruined the game to any degree
NFL on Fox rules analyst and former NFL
VP officiating Mike Pereira joining the
Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison in for
it's also follow Mike on Twitter at Mike
Pereira obviously you mentioned you
talked to people around the league and
current officials is this something is
there any gray area with current
officials that you've talked to with the
passing of this rule and what kind of
video will they be showing to the
players and training camp because I know
there has to be a video behind this and
I know it's gonna be coming out soon
what kind of video will we see in terms
of this rule that the players will see
and also the fans well what they're
gonna see is what is illegal and what is
legal I mean you have to in a video you
have to be clear and definitive
about what is illegal and then you have
to be clear and definitive as to what is
not so if there's a corner for example
that's bracing for contact from a
pulling guard and he lowers is said to
protect himself
that's not initiating contact he's
trying to defend themself those show
instances like that but it's an
important video it's a very important
video you know to show the teams and the
clubs and they're going out now they're
starting now they're gonna visit all 32
teams and the entire coaching staff of
all 32 teams and they will take this
video they will leave it for them to
show their players and and then when
they when the officials go to the
training camps in August
they'll also then personally show it to
the players and answer any questions you
know it's gonna be met with disdain I
think from you know the current players
you know it's it changes the game to
where it takes money out of their pocket
conceivably for something that is
incidental but incidental to me is not
what the league is looking for so this
video if it's clear and you you know
they always told me hey don't put iffy
ones on there put one nobody oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah that's that or oh yeah oh
yeah that's not but that's probably a
smaller percentage of the number of hits
clearly a smaller percentage of the
number of hits that you know people will
say well what about that one and then
you kind of go and and I say this really
I say it really substantially I've
always felt this way if you look at a
hit and I've always said this about this
college
targeting rule and you have to go yeah
is it or isn't it then it isn't and and
I would hope that the league leans in
that direction NFL on Fox rules analyst
Mike for a couple more for you Mike
the revision to the catch rule and I
know this is something to me you have
discussed on length many different times
I know what the rule was if a player was
in the act of going to the ground while
catching it he had to survive the ground
now there the rule
has been changes he's got possession two
feet makes a football act all of that do
you think we'll see more fumbles now or
more incomplete passes I think there's
still a little bit of gray area in there
Mike that still was going to need to be
clarified especially when that play
finally happens during the season well
there is gray area I thought they did a
good job of taking this notion of having
to survive the ground out of it no now
look at you're still going to be going
to the ground but the fact of the matter
is is that you have to have the three
elements of to get a catch and and
that's the same whether you're on the
feet and not going to the ground or if
you're on your way to the ground and
it's pretty simple it's controlled two
feet or another body part and then a
football move which if you're upright
could be three steps the third step
could be turning up field and extending
I mean they did a pretty good job
although they've done that before but I
was concerned about that last portion of
it that you know or have time to do a
football move even though you don't do
it you know which becomes then the real
gray area I think it's clear because
Jesse James is you know play with
Pittsburgh you know that should have
been a touchdown right it smelled like a
touchdown felt like a touchdown
so the dez bryant's is catch many years
ago so did Calvin Johnson back in 2010
so we got off track and I say we because
I was a part of that but we got off
track with the rule and and I think
because of replay you know I actually
argue with Dean Blandino my good buddy
is with it you know he thinks that you
know they made it simple for the
officials and made it understandable for
the officials and now you're making it
more gray and and I argued with him and
said how can you say you made it simple
with the officials when what did the
officials rule with Jesse James they
rule touchdown what did they rule with
there's Brian on the field they ruled
catch what did they rule with Calvin
Johnson one rule touchdown the other one
came over kind of sheepishly and
incomplete and then they
with incomplete so officials make calls
on the field quite often based on the I
test it's instinct it's how it feels
did he have it long enough and to me
that's that ought to be left right there
and replay ought to be out of that
trying to make this subjective decision
at a different speed than the officials
actually see it I really think it's a
mistake leaving replay in there it's
better I do think it's better I disagree
again with Dean I talked to him last
night and he tried to convince me that
it wasn't better III think it's better
it will be clearer and it will take
those ones that look so much like a
catch and they'll leave them as a catch
and I think we'll all be better for it
actually well just know I'll be blowing
up the Twitter handle of at my career on
the first fumble I see a lot of them
will be down by contact right there's a
big discount if he gets control and he's
touched on the way to the ground and
then the ball comes out after he hits
the ground after a football move then it
would be down by contact but hey you
know if your receiver on the way to the
ground and you want to stretch to gain
another yard go ahead you're doing it at
your own risk if you just want to you
know secure the ball and go to the
ground with the ball securely in your
possession then you know you're gonna
have a catch but you're gonna be at a
risk of fumble if you weren't touched
and you try to reach the gain an
additional yard hey Mike I won't hold
you back from the lake anymore you can
go back to catching on when I heard you
were guest hosting I drove all the way
back from Medford Oregon to Sacramento
California so I did not even think about
catching another steelhead and get to
talk to my my buddy Kirk oh I appreciate
the time Mike have a good one may I talk
to you soon you got it all right that
was Mike Pereira in a fellow on Fox the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience